what's funny is the migrants are
actually the ones that are in the hotels
it was an article I think it was in the
post and they're they're talking about
uh they're talking about how unhappy
they are with the food they like any
everything else but they're basically
like hey like this one woman goes we
came here uh she's a Russian she goes we
came here to avoid mobilization for the
war said Leela usmanov who fled Russia
with her husband and she goes we have
three kids 16 10 and three
we don't want to fight against our own
ukrainians or Russians same people she
goes we're grateful to the US government
but complain that the food the city was
providing at the Swanky Hotel turned
shelter was less than nutritious my
husband and I have high blood sugar and
the food isn't very good for us our kids
don't want to eat it she also added come
here in the evening and you will see a
giant pile of wasted food they're
throwing out 90 of the food here isn't
eaten well welcome to America welcome
this is uh you're gonna get poisoned
they're gonna get but another guy goes
you've been here three months it's only
temporary until I can get a work permit
and find some work all I want to do is
start working and build a life
he said of the shelter this is a huge
help it's clean it's safe but then he
goes on as well to complain about the
food he goes they're good with the kids
they're very attentive but he goes You
Know listen we can't eat the food here
he goes it's it's not good it's not good
for our kids
um you know he goes we don't have a
kitchen the food isn't good for the kids
we would rather make our own food so
everybody all of these uh migrants by
the way these are the most desperate
people on the planet at the moment they
have nothing they have nothing and their
main problem is American Cuisine that's
how bad the food is in this country
that's absolutely terrible the food is
in this country they would rather starve
or go hungry than eat the food and God
only knows what we're providing them by
the way God only knows what they're
getting we're probably giving them pop
arts and chicken nuggets they
are getting
what we feed our children I mean it's
not something that we don't feed our own
kids but they're so horrified which is
again it's like this should wake
Americans up like Americans should get
woken up by this they should go the most
desperate people in the world refuse to
eat our food they can't eat the food
they go this is poison how is everyone
eating this this is actually poison
and Americans have been so desensitized
and people a lot of people have just
given up and when you have a family you
got to feed them and you got to go to
grocery stores you gotta buy this
whatever Tyson churns out or
whatever Dole or whatever these
companies are doing you got to buy it
but it's so hilarious to me that people
that are here for like five minutes eat
it and they spit it out they go no no
this is poison we can't we can't give
this to our children this is crazy and
uh you know it's I this is like when we
drop those care packages on Afghanistan
while they were blowing we were blowing
them up and we dropped like you know fun
dip and Pop-Tarts on Afghans and they
were like go for it don't worry about
the war we got you covered here we go
and we're just bombing them with Reese's
Peanut Butter Cups and all of those
people were just entirely like what the
is it if you give our food to
anyone else no matter how bad their lot
in life is if you give our food to
anyone they're stunned they're shocked
by it they can't even believe it they
don't if you bring people over here and
these people aren't from Europe it's not
like they were living in France they're
not wealthy there's about people that
lived in an Italian Villa these are
people that were ran out of their
country by a flood or a crazy government
and they're still going what the
are you giving our children to eat they
care more than people that live in this
country about the food they care more
on Sunday the post reported that at
least 41 migrants have been arrested on
charges including domestic violence at
The Roosevelt Hotel shelter on East 45th
that's well this is the food this is
what happens uh with the food
well this isn't good it's not good when
people start beating each other up
you're you just got here you gotta wait
a little bit to start hitting your wife